so we have three functions that are
graphed here we have f of X graphed in
this dotted magenta we have G of X in
this green and then we have H of X and
this dotted purple and then we have
three potential equations that could
also be used to define functions and
what I want you to do is think about
which of these which of these equations
match up to which of these function
graphs so let's go through them one by
one so this first one is reasonably
straightforward this is just a
straight-up quadratic right over here y
is equal to 1/2 x squared minus 9 halves
and we see that the coefficient on the
second degree term or the highest degree
term right over here is positive it is
1/2 so this is going to be an
upward-opening parabola it's going to
look something it's going to look
something like that and when we look at
all of these options over here there's
only one upward-opening parabola and
that is G of X so we know that if this
is if this has got to be one of these
three this right over here is G of X so
we could say that G of X is equal to 1/2
x squared minus 9 halves another
giveaway that G of X or that G is being
described by Y is equal to 1/2 x squared
minus 9 halves as you see when X is
equal to 0 we have our y intercept at
negative 9 halves which is the same
thing as negative 4 and 1/2 and you see
that is indeed the case for G right over
there it's when x is 0 Y is negative 4
and 1/2 so we can feel pretty confident
about that now let's look at these next
two and what I'm going to do let me try
to rewrite them in a neutral color so we
don't use blue yet so let's think about
this one y is equal to negative 1/10
times X plus 3 times x squared minus 9
now we could take the trouble of
multiplying all of this stuff out or we
could just think about what is the
highest degree term I'm going to look
like and we could also think about what
does the lowest degree term look like
what is the constant term so the highest
degree term is going to be negative 1/10
times X times x squared so it's going to
so this is going to be Y is equal to
negative 1/10 X to the 3rd power then
you're going to have a bunch of other
terms in there
you're gonna have a bunch of other terms
in there and then you're gonna have your
lowest maybe I'll write a plus although
item it might be a minus but then you're
gonna have a bunch of other terms there
and then you're gonna have your lowest
degree term which is going to be
negative nine times three which is
negative twenty seven times negative one
tenth well that's just going to be
positive twenty seven over ten which is
the same thing as two two point seven
now just from this without even knowing
all of this business in the middle we
can start to think about what this graph
is actually is actually going to look
like first of all we see it as a third
degree it is a third degree polynomial
or it's a third degree expression I
guess we could say and it's coefficient
on the third degree term is negative so
that means it's going to have end
behavior like negative x to the third X
to the third X to the third looks like
this negative negative x to the third
negative x to the third will look like
something like this
so it's end behavior is going to look
like that we don't we can think about
what it does in the middle it might jump
up and do something like that but that's
what its end behavior is going to be has
end behavior like like negative x to the
third now which of these graphs have
that type of end behavior well it's
pretty clear that H of X when X is very
negative H of X is positive just like
this when X is very positive H of X is
very negative it's the only of these
three graphs that have that behavior so
we can feel pretty confident that this
is H of X now if we're not sure we could
also look at the y-intercept right over
here when all of the other when X is
equal to 0 all these other terms are 0
and so Y is going to be 2.7 and we see
that is indeed the case right over here
when x is 0 Y is 2 point 7 so that gives
us some confidence as well now let's
look at this third this third expression
and obviously we could just deduce that
there's only one one equation left and
one function left so this has got to be
f of X but let's say we didn't know that
let's see how we could reason it out so
once again let's think about multiplying
let's think about multiplying we'll
figure out what the highest degree term
is well the highest degree term is going
to be one tenth times x squared times X
square
so we could rewrite this one as
one-tenth x squared times x squared is X
to the fourth power then we're going to
have a bunch of terms and then our
lowest degree term is going to be nine
times nine times 1/10 that's 81 divided
by 10 so that is eight point one so what
type of end behavior is this going to
have you have an even degree polynomial
right over here and it has a positive
coefficient so it's going to have end
behavior like a second-degree polynomial
with a positive coefficient or it's
going to have end behavior like x
squared so it's going to look when X is
really negative it's going to be really
positive and then when X is really
positive it's going to be really
positive so it's end behavior it's going
to look like that and it might do some
business in between well which of these
graphs do that well it's pretty clear
that F definitely has that type of end
that type of end behavior it does
something a little interesting in the
middle and if we wanted to be sure we
could look at this intercept right over
here when X is zero all these other
terms are going to be zero and you're
going to be left just with this
y-intercept which is eight point one and
so when X is zero we do see indeed that
F is sitting here at eight point one so
we can feel pretty confident that that
right over there is f of X